ONE CALENDAR          CALIFORNIH
ONE CALENDAR          CALIFORNI
ONE CALENDAR          CALIFORNIO
BECOME A SANCTUARY CITY
FOR MARIJUANA.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT."
♪ ♪
GOOD EVENING, I'M BRET BAIER.
WE ARE COMING TO LIVE TONIGHT
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
TONIGHT, NEW QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
DID OR DID NOT DO ABOUT DOMESTIC
ABUSE TO GALLANTLY MAKE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST ROB PORTER.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI TODAY IT
SEEMS TO DISPUTE THE WHITE HOUSE
TIMELINE ABOUT WHETHER THE
SECURITY CLEARANCE PROCEDURE WAS
FINISHED OR ONGOING WHEN PORTER
QUIT HIS JOB LAST WEEK.
AND WE HAVE LEARNED PORTER WAS
BEING CONSIDERED FOR A PROMOTION
RIGHT UP UNTIL HIS RESIGNATION.
JOHN ROBERTS ALONG WITH WITH ALL
OF THIS.
>> WE ARE ALMOST ENDED A 7 HERE,
SOMETHING A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK
THE WHITE HOUSE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PUT ABLE TO PUT AWAY.
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THAT THEY
WERE CONSIDERING EXPANDING THE
ROYALTY CAN INCLUDE SOME OF THE
DUTIES OF DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF
JOHN CARROLL TO BE THE DRUGS
ARE -- THE WEEK -- BEFORE THAT,
SAME ALLEGATIONS AGAINST PORTER
WERE NOT KNOWN UNTIL RECENTLY,
PROMPTING A COMPETING NARRATIVE.
A DAY AFTER THE WHITE HOUSE
SUGGESTED THE FBI FAILED TO
ILLUMINATE THE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST ROB PORTER IN A TIMELY
FASHION, FBI DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY TRIED TO TURN
THE WHITE HOUSE UNDER BUS.
>> THE FBI SUBMITTED A PARTIAL
REPORT ON THE INVESTIGATION IN
QUESTION IN MARCH, AND THEN A
COMPLETED BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATION IN LATE JULY THAT
COME OUT SOON THEREAFTER, WE
RECEIVED FOLLOW-UP INQUIRY, AND
WE DID THE FOLLOW-UP AND
PROVIDED THAT INFORMATION IN
NOVEMBER, AND THEN WE
ADMINISTRATIVELY CLOSE THE FILE
IN JANUARY, AND THEN EARLIER
THIS MONTH, WE RECEIVED SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND
PASS THAT ON AS WELL.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE, WHICH IS
ONLY SET OF IN THE FULL EXTENT
OF THE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
PORTER LAST TUESDAY, SHIFTED
ITS TIMELINE TODAY,
ACKNOWLEDGING THE FBI DID GIVE
INFORMATION ON PORTER TO THE
WHITE HOUSE PERSONNEL SECURITY
OFFICE.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE PERSONNEL
SECURITY OFFICES, STAFFED BY --
RECEIVE INFORMATION ASKED THEM
WHAT THEY CONSIDERED TO BE THE
FINAL BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION
REPORT IN NOVEMBER.
IN THE VIEW OF PERSONAL SECURITY
OFFICE, THE FBI'S JULY REPORT
REQUIRES SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
INVESTIGATORY FIELDWORK BEFORE
PERSONNEL SECURITY OFFICE COULD
BEGIN TO EVALUATE THE
INFORMATION FOR ADJUDICATION.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE SECURITY
PERSONNEL OFFICE, LOCATED ACROSS
PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE, HANDLES
INFORMATION FOR SECURITY
CLEARANCES.
THE PRESS SECRETARY TODAY SAID
THE OFFICES HAD NOT COMPLETED
THE DATA GATHERING FOR PORTER'S
SECURITY CLEARANCE AT THE TIME
HE RESIGNED.
>> AS DIRECTOR WRAY SAID,
INFORMATION WAS STILL COMING TO
THE WHITE HOUSE PERSONNEL OFFICE
IN FEBRUARY.
>> IN TWO APPEARANCES TODAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP REFUSED TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT PORTER
AND THE ISSUE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, DO YOU HAVE AN
ANSWER?
>> DEMOCRATS SAW AN OPENING AND
JUMPED ON IT.
>> I HAVEN'T HEARD THE PRESIDENT
SAY SOMETHING DIRECTLY ABOUT HOW
BAD DOMESTIC ABUSE IS.
YOU KNOW, TO A SPOKESPERSON GET
OUT AND SAY SOMETHING IS NOT
ENOUGH.
>> PUTTING ANY ON CAMERA COMMENT
ABOUT THE CONTROVERSY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO KEEP
THE FOCUS ON HIS AGENDA, MEETING
WITH SHERIFF'S ON IMMIGRATION, W
WITH SHERIFF'S ON IMMIGRATION, R
WITH SHERIFF'S ON IMMIGRATION, I
WITH SHERIFF'S ON IMMIGRATION, G
WITH SHERIFF'S ON IMMIGRATION, H
WITH SHERIFF'S ON IMMIGRATION,
WITH SHERIFF'S ON IMMIGRATION, O
WITH SHERIFF'S ON IMMIGRATION, '
WITH SHERIFF'S ON IMMIGRATION, T
STAND BY WHILE FOREIGN STEEL AND
ALUMINUM ARE DUMPED INTO THE
U.S.
>> MY ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
REVIEWING THE PORTS AND
CONSIDERING ALL OPTIONS, AND
PART OF THE OPTIONS WOULD BE
TARIFFS COMING IN.
SPEAK BUT THAT
REPORT EVOKED WORDS OF CAUTION.
>> I THINK WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL
THAT WE DON'T START A RECIPROCAL
BATTLE ON TARIFFS.
>> INVOKING NATIONAL SECURITY,
WHEN I THINK IT IS REALLY HARD
TO MAKE THAT CASE, INVITES
RETALIATION AND WOULD BE
PROBLEMATIC FOR US.
>> AND AS CONGRESS STARTS
KICKING UP DACA AND IMMIGRATION
FROM, PRESIDENT TRUMP GAVE
DEMOCRATS TO SHOVE, TWEETING
"NEGOTIATIONS ON DACA HAVE
BEGUN.
REPUBLICANS WANT TO MAKE A DEAL
AND DEMOCRATS SAY THEY WANT TO
MAKE A DEAL.
WOULDN'T IT BE GREAT IF WE COULD
FINALLY, AFTER SO MANY YEARS,
SALLY DACA PUZZLE?
THIS WILL BE OUR LAST CHANCE.
THERE WILL NEVER BE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY.
MARCH 5TH."
IN HIS CONGRESSIONAL MEANING, --
IN HIS CONGRESSIONAL MEANING, -
>> I THINK WE CAN GO BIPARTISAN
ON INFRASTRUCTURE, IT MAY BE
EVEN MORE SO THAN WE CAN ON DACA
EVEN MORE SO THAN WE CAN ON DAC
DACA.
BECAUSE THE DIFFERENCE IS, WE
WANT TO HELP DACA.
YOU DON'T.
OKAY?
I'M KIDDING.
I'M SURE YOU DO.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE CONTINUES TO
INSIST THAT IT WILL NOT TRIM
DOWN ITS DACA PLAN TO GET
APPROVAL FROM CONGRESS,
INCLUDING -- PATH TO CITIZENSHIP
1.8 MILLION PEOPLE FOR A
PORTABLE AND OTHER SECURITY
MEASURES, AND ENTITY CHAIN
MIGRATION, AND AN END TO THE
VISA LOTTERY PROGRAM.
BRET, THE WHITE HOUSE HOPES THAT
WHEN IT IS ALL DONE, ITS PLAN
WILL BE THE LAST ONE STANDING.
>> Bret: JOHN, WHERE ARE WE ON
THE POSSIBILITY OF THE PRESIDENT
SITTING DOWN WITH BOB MUELLER
AND WHAT HIS TEAM IS SAYING?
>> MY SENSE TELLS ME THAT HIS
LEGAL TEAM IS LEANING FIRMLY
AGAINST THE IDEA.
THEY ARE READING AN OLD CASE
ABOUT MIKE SP, THE CLINTON-ERA
SECRETARY FROM THE LATE 1990s,
WHICH FOUND IN THE CASE THAT
THE PRESIDENT, THOSE SEEKING
INFORMATION FROM THE PRESIDENT,
IN THIS CASE, AN INTERVIEW, MUST
DEMONSTRATE WITH SPECIFICITY WHY
IT IS LIKELY THAT THE SUBPOENAED
MATERIALS HERE CONTAIN IMPORTANT
EVIDENCE ON WHY THIS EVIDENCE IS
NOT PRACTICALLY AVAILABLE FROM
ANOTHER SOURCE.
HIS LEGAL TEAM PUT OUT A PAGE
ABOUT A MONTH AGO SAYING THAT
THEY PRODUCED TENS UPON TENS OF
THOUSANDS DOCUMENTS WITH 37
PEOPLE, EITHER FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE OR THE TRANSITION,
AND HIS LEGAL TEAM SAYS THAT
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF ANY
KIND OF COLLUSION HERE SO FAR,
NO EVIDENCE OF OBSTRUCTION
BECAUSE OF THE PRODUCTION OF
THESE DOCUMENTS, AND THAT WHAT
WAS HAPPENING WAS THAT IT WAS A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AND NOT A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, AND THAT THE
PRESIDENT CANNOT OBSTRUCT A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE OPERATION
BECAUSE HE, BY VIRTUE OF HIS
POSITION, IS INVOLVED IN ALL OF
THAT.
GIVEN THE PREPONDERANCE OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY ARE LOOKING
AT, THAT THEY MAY NOT DO AN
INTERVIEW WITH MUELLER.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT POSITION
HAS FULLY BEEN MADE YET.
>> Bret: WE SHOULD POINT OUT
THAT WE ASKED FOR SOMEONE TO
COME OUT HERE AND TALK ABOUT A
HOST OF ISSUES, INCLUDING THE
WRAY TIMELINE.
THEY DIDN'T SEND SOMEBODY OUT
TODAY.
NO THERE WERE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AND THAT.
>> THERE HAS BEEN AN EVOLVING
NARRATIVE HERE.
NOW THEY HAVE GOTTEN BLINDSIDED
BY THIS LAST TUESDAY.
THEY SCRAMBLE TO TRY TO GET OUT
SOMETHING THAT WOULD HOLD THE
FIRE LINE BACK FOR A LITTLE
OVERWHELM THEM.
THE ONE PERSON WHO COULD REALLY
CLEAR ALL OF THIS UP WOULD BE
THE CHIEF OF STAFF, JOHN KELLY.
REMEMBER, THEY WROTE ABOUT IT
SOMETIME AGO, "TELL THE TRUTH,
TELL IT EARLY, TELL IT YOURSELF,
AND TELL IT ALL."
THE ONE PERSON I COULD DO THAT